ah hello thank you thank you it's very
good to be here I like living in
Southern California I'm kind of obsessed
with all the local newscasters in the
area like all the local news affiliates
I love how they always do this kind of
like singsong II childish intro into
news stories like they never just start
a news story they have to find a weird
way into it you know what I mean well
they'll just be like eenie meenie miney
moe catch a tiger in your neighborhood a
local zoo has Reese is the tiger loose
you can just mention the missing tiger
and I'll take that information and run
away you don't have to be a coy about
your news and be like me Chinese me play
joke me put poison in your coke tragedy
strikes Beijing today seven dead two
horny they do that then they'll do the
other weird thing where they're like
we've all heard of the old woman who
lives in a shoe but an old man who has
sex with shoes Tom Snyder's on scene
today I'll just cut to an old guy having
sex with a shoe
it's an odd way to do your news just be
like we've all heard of the Blue Man
Group but three bodies have been found
in the LA River police are baffled I'm
trying to online date it's a nightmare I
use OkCupid coz it's free
trying to find my soul mate don't want
to spend a lot I want to flash a lot of
cash gogo diggers please it's really
funny like starting the process of
online dating like you really see the
differences in levels of fear going into
it between men and women like it's so
radically disproportionate like guys
number one fear with online dating is
you're gonna show up to the date and the
girl is not gonna look exactly like your
photo is generally the fair guys have
right she'll be a bit bigger right
women's number one fear is that they'll
be murdered
radically disproportionate that is guys
are just like I hope she's not an ogre
bug
women are like I hope my head still with
me at the end of this day well like half
the time when I email women I'm
basically just trying to say I'm not a
sociopath like the first couple of
exchanges like my profile picture is
just a pile of guns and knives and me
just be like you know doesn't work I've
been on - I've been on two online dates
I haven't been on any more and the
reason is both times the girl that
showed up was super nice really sweet
but easily like 55 pounds bigger than
her profile picture you know like a liar
that's fine but that's up in both times
that's happened twice if that happens a
third time I'm gonna murder that girl
then we'll both be right I think our
grandparents generation was like the
last sweet really romantic generation
like that's where you hear all the click
crazy stories there's like I married
your grandmother the day I met her just
like these weird impulsive romantic
decisions and I was thinking about that
and it finally dawned on me all of our
grandparents sweet romantic stories it's
just Asperger's that nobody was
diagnosing back then like I'm not trying
to be mean but just no social cues like
they don't understand what they're doing
is like crazy creepy inappropriate
behavior how to meet your grandmother
well I used to see her around the block
thought she was pretty cute stop found
out where she worked every day I would
wait for her to come home off the bus
and I would propose marriage to her for
200 days in a row I propose marriage to
your grandmother and every day she say
no who are you no you can and all the
two hours of the first day she said yes
and made me the happiest man in the
world now what do you think about that
it sounds like you defeated a broken
woman like it's the 1950s grandmas got
no other options like what are you gonna
do go to the police
hi yeah there's a guy who's been
following me around Oh sounds like we
got a case case of the purple loves I'm
really scared he's outside my place all
the time foul this one of the boys will
be boys
[Applause]
you